special counsel robert muller apparently
complained to attorney general william
barra now democrats are all mad about a+
chaos continues in venezuela i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
okay so today's episode is titled bar
brawl and it is indeed a brawl over
william bar see it's funny we'll get to
all of that in just one second first
after a childhood full of unsuccessful
attempts to lie to your mother do you
really think she won't be able to tell
the difference between a last-minute
Mother's Day gift and something truly
thoughtful this Mother's Day don't
settle for anything less than the
biggest and brightest bouquets from
1-800 flowers calm right now 1-800
flowers has a great deals for Mom like
24 assorted roses for 24 bucks there's
only a buck per rose
I love 1-800 flowers every time I need
to send my wife flowers whenever I go on
the road I send my wife flowers whenever
I whenever she does something cool like
past the boar's I send her flowers from
1-800 flowers because their flowers are
the best she loves them every time with
a bright and beautiful mix of orange
yellow and pink blooms these assorted
roses are guaranteed to make her smile
assorted roses are the perfect way to
surprise all of the moms in your life
wife sister grandma roses from 1-800
flowers are picked at their peak from
premier farms and shipped overnight to
ensure freshness 24 assorted roses for
24 bucks it's an amazing offer but you
have to hurry because it expires on
Friday trust 1-800 flowers to make mom
feel loved this Mother's Day order today
from 1-800 flowers com to order those 24
assorted roses for 24 bucks go to 1-800
flowers com Shapiro's that's one eight
hundred Flowers comm slash apparel and
make sure she knows that you put some
thought into it because she's a
bloodhound she's gonna find out if you
didn't go check it out at 1-800 flowers
calm / apparel the offer expires on
Friday 1-800 flowers calm / appear oh
alright so controversy controversy a day
of controversy Democrats in the media
but I repeat myself are very upset at
Attorney General William Bar deeply
upset at Attorney General William Bar
why you ask why would they be upset at
the Attorney General after all the
Attorney General simply provided a while
back month ago month and a half ago a
four-page synopsis of the findings of
the Muller report and then we actually
got to see the Muller report all 448
pages of it and it turns out that
attorney general Barr accurately
summarized the conclusions of the Mullen
report which is exactly what he said he
was doing you don't have to take
anybody's word for you can read the
mullah report you can also read bars
letter so where's the controversy ah
apparently Robert Muller was very upset
very mad that William bars original
synopsis of the findings did not include
the mood of Robert Muller's team in the
summary I kid you not he's whining
Robert Muller what's happen I've been
very fair to Robert Muller I've been
suggesting for years literally years
that Robert Muller is an honest broker
that we ought to let him do his job and
when this is all done he had done his
job he had done a thorough investigation
not only of Russian collusion of which
there was none but also a thorough
investigation of supposed obstruction of
justice and it turns out there was
nothing prosecutable there and that's
what Barre said he said listen there's
no evidence of collusion that is
Muller's finding also the he says in the
letter itself the william bar letter
itself suggests that robert muller did
not make a finding on obstruction of
justice they declined to make a finding
on obstruction of justice and that in
the end the Attorney General declined to
prosecute because the evidence was not
sufficient to sustain a prosecution that
is what the bar letter says but bottom
line Democrats in the media don't like
but that's what the Moller report said
and they can't blame Muller because
they've been buying votive candles of
them for years and they don't wanna sell
those things on eBay so instead they're
gonna suggest that William bar is the
big baddie behind it all he's the guy
who hid things from the American public
he lied to us all now you may be
wondering how did he lie when three
weeks after the release of his letter he
then released the entire underlying
report which you can read and is public
and is on the best seller list and you
can buy from Amazon in print edition how
is that a lie like that it's the worst
lie ever it's like if he's lying that's
the dumbest stupidest lie ever so I read
a book and then I decide I'm gonna write
a review of the book so I write a review
of the book and the book is publicly
available now you can say that I
mischaracterized the book in my initial
review that's fine we can have arguments
over that but to say that I lied about
the book when the book is publicly
available particularly why I'm in a
government position I'm jut not just a
reviewer I'm in a government position
and it's my job to summarize the
findings and the findings do match up
with the findings of the Mugler
report that is not a lie here's what's
really going on here robert muller is
pissy he's mad today he's mad because
his report is really about president
Trump's impeachment his report is that
he doesn't like President Trump and that
President Trump is a very mean bad man
who says bad things about people and
then tries to manipulate things behind
the scenes but fails that is what
mothers report is about not that Trump
was engaged in criminally prosecuted
activity not that Trump was engaged in
something that would result in an
obstruction of justice charge but that
Trump was engaged in things that Robert
Muller and his team don't like and that
bars initial summary of the report
didn't include all those things in his
summary which is not William bars job so
basically what Muller wants it is he
wanted to have it both ways he wanted to
completely abdicate by not suggesting an
obstruction of justice charge and then
he wanted Barr to do his dirty work for
him by releasing Muller's summary
publicly to humiliate the president but
not prosecute him which is not the job
of the special counsel the job of the
special counsel is to investigate
criminal activity it is not to
investigate and publicized mean activity
or embarrassing activity that is not
inside his mandate his mandate is to
investigate criminal activity and if he
didn't find any then you don't get to
whine when someone says there was no
criminal activity that was found here
lots of embarrassing stuff sure and we
got to read all of it it's not as the
bar has buried the report the report
again has been read by apparently by
poll numbers three percent of Americans
there's a pretty large number of people
reading a particular report now the
reason all this is cropping up again is
because they bombshell Washington Post
report that came out last night now you
can tell that this thing is all staged
because William bar was set to testify
in front of the Senate Judiciary
Committee this morning when in fact he
did testify in front of the Senate
Judiciary Committee this morning but
before that happened before that
happened late last night there was a
report a bombshell report from the
Washington Post and this bombshell
report from The Washington Post was
titled Muller complained to bar about
memo on key findings now what you would
take away from that headline is that
Muller complaints bar about the memos
key findings that somehow bar had not
properly summarized the key findings of
the mullah report but that is not what
the Washington Post report itself
actually says here's what the Washington
Post report itself actually says special
counsel robert muller or a letter in
late march complaining to attorney
general william bar that a four-page
memo to congress describing the
principal conclusions of the
investigation into president Trump did
not fully capture the context nature and
substance of Miller's work according to
a copy of the letter reviewed Tuesday by
the Washington Post I do have a full
copy of the letter which I'll read to
you in a second because we always bring
you all the information you need to know
even if you disagree the letter and a
subsequent phone call between the two
men reveal the degree to which the
longtime colleagues and friends
disagreed as they handled the legally
and politically fraught task of
investigating the president Democrats in
Congress are likely to scrutinize
Muller's complaints to bar as they
contemplate the prospect of opening
impeachment proceedings and Maul how
hard to press for Muller himself to
testify publicly well they obviously
want Muller to testify publicly because
now they have information that Muller
would like to crap on the president I
mean that's basically what this letter
shows at the time Muller's letter was
sent to bar on March 27th Barr had days
prior announced that Muller did not find
a conspiracy between the Trump campaign
and Russian officials seeking to
interfere in the 2016 presidential
election in his memo to Congress Barr
also said that Muller had not reached a
conclusion about whether Trump had tried
to obstruct justice but that Barr had
reviewed the evidence and found it
insufficients who supports such a charge
all of which is perfectly accurate how
do we know that that's perfectly
accurate because the report is available
for the 9th time you can read the report
you're not burying something if it's
right here if I kill somebody and then I
leave the body in the middle of the
street
that is not me burying the body okay the
body is in public view the report is in
public view this is the worst cover-up
of all time in other words days after
bars announcement Muller wrote the
previously undisclosed letter to the
Justice Department laying out his
concerns in stark terms that shocked
senior Justice Department officials
according to people familiar with the
discussions anonymous sources I wonder
who they could be might they be I don't
know people in Muller's team the most
honest team of all time Muller wrote the
summary letter the department sends to
Congress and released to the public late
in the afternoon of March 24th did not
fully capture the context nature and
substance of this office's work
and conclusions because it didn't
include all the mood music in other
words he just had the bottom line it
just had the bottom stark line no
collusion no evidence necessary to
sustain a in obstruction prosecution
done but it didn't include you know the
mood music it didn't include the keniji
of the Muller report it didn't include
the rose petals strewn across the floor
for the Democratic in features to find
mullah wrote there is now public
confusion about critical aspects of the
results of our investigation this
threatens to undermine a central purpose
for which the department appointed the
special counsel to assure full public
confidence in the outcome of the
investigations the letter made a key
request that by release the 448 page
reports introductions and executive
summaries and it made initial suggested
redactions for doing so according to
Justice Department officials a spokesman
for Muller declined to comment Justice
Department officials said on Tuesday
they were taken aback by the tone of
Muller's letter and that it came as a
surprise to them that he had such
concerns until they received the letter
they believed Muller was in agreement
with them on the process of reviewing
the report and rejecting certain types
of information a process that took
several weeks Barr has testified to
Congress previously that Muller declined
the opportunity to review his four-page
memo to lawmakers that distilled the
essence of the special counsels findings
in his letter to Barr Mulla wrote that
the redaction process need not too late
release of the enclosed materials
release at this time would not only
would alleviate the misunderstandings
that have arisen and would answer
congressional and public questions about
the nature and outcome of our
investigation so buried in paragraph 14
of this story all the way down in
paragraph 14 is the key element of the
story and the only element that actually
matters a day after Muller sends his
letter to bar the two men spoke by phone
for about 15 minutes according to law
enforcement officials in that call
Muller said he was concerned that media
coverage of the obstruction
investigation was misguided and created
public misunderstandings about the
offices work according to Justice
Department officials in other words what
Muller was really concerned about was
not what Barr had written but what
everyone was taking away from what Barr
had written presumably he was mad that a
lot of the media coverage was about
Trump being exonerated Muller felt that
he wasn't really exonerated Muller felt
that there was a lot of underlying
embarrassing material and that if Barr
had just said note a lot of underlying
embarrassing material that all of this
could have been avoided that is not bars
job he is the Attorney General his job
is to prosecute or to decline
prosecution Muller did not express
similar concerns about the public
discussion of the investigation of
Russia's election interference the
official said in other words he was very
very upset and very very mad about the
obstruction stuff but he didn't care he
didn't care that bar had summarized his
findings on Russian collusion by saying
there's no Russian collusion bar has
testified previously he did not know
whether Muller supported his conclusion
on obstruction so Barr has not lied
anywhere in here he's correct Barr
didn't know whether Muller supported his
conclusion on obstruction because Muller
didn't come to a conclusion on
obstruction
this is Muller's fault not bars in other
words when Barr pressed Muller on
whether he thought bars memo to Congress
was inaccurate Muller said he did not
paint let's underline and bold that when
bar pressed Muller on whether he thought
bars memo to Congress was inaccurate
Muller said he did not but felt that the
media coverage of it was misrepresenting
the investigation officials said Wow Wow
so in other words the media sucks at
their job and therefore the media are
now gonna blame William Bar for them
sucking at their job because people in
accurately covered bars letter and
stretched it in one direction or the
other
thus Muller was mad and thus his bar is
fault amazing hey second will gets you
more of this because I want to break
this down info I think this is Muller's
fault really I think this is Muller's
problem and Muller's fault I'll explain
in just a second first Mother's Day is
coming up as you know there's absolutely
nothing most of us wouldn't do to make
sure the special moms in our life are
happy Sherri's berries has special
Mother's Day berries designed just for
Mom they're topped with chocolate chips
pink shimmer sugar swizzles you choose
your delivery date to ensure mom gets
your gift of cherries berries exactly
when you want her to and your
satisfaction is always guaranteed let me
explain something to you
honestly cherries berries is the
greatest chocolate like substance on
planet Earth it is freaking phenomenal
it is so good I mean they're a sponsor
but after my wife tasted this stuff I
went and I bought like an entire giant
box of Sherri's berries products because
they are so unbelievably good this is
the these are the best sweets you will
ever taste don't wait until the last
minute on this one visit berries calm
today to order of freshly dipped
strawberries starting in 1999
for the moms in your life to make mom
really happy you can double the berries
for just 10 bucks more they do have some
kosher products go check it out Mother's
Day is Sunday May 12th
so visit berries calm that's ber RI es
calm click on the microphone in the
upper right corner enter my code Ben
show that is Barry's calm click on the
microphone code Ben show go check it out
right now
ok so in other words even according to
the Washington Post report itself Muller
doesn't think that Barr did anything
wrong he just doesn't like that bar
didn't include the mood music
he didn't include the wafting the
wafting scented candles he didn't
include the tone and the tenor hidden
include the shading in the substance
that's that's what he didn't include the
actual conclusions he was right of
course but he didn't include any of the
stuff that Muller really wanted him to
include which was the seething undertone
of disdain for the president that's what
he wanted in there which is obvious from
the Muller report when you read the
Muller report the second half of the
Muller report is basically god this guy
Trump he's terrible he's terrible I wish
we could prosecute him but you know we
can't really so we're just gonna instead
of us just saying we can't prosecute him
we're gonna just throw that the bar and
then it's on bar if bar doesn't
prosecute him but really we don't like
the guy and he's a jerk and then bar
writes okay so I'm not prosecuting him
and mother's like well why didn't you
include the fact he's a jerk why didn't
you say all the stuff we wanted you to
about how he's mean and petty and
ridiculous why didn't you include all
that stuff and bar sitting there like
well that's not my job I'm the Attorney
General I am not in fact your third
grade teacher who is summarizing your
beautiful essay on Alice in Wonderland
yes I read Alice in Wonderland when I
was in third grade in any case this is
the push from the media and it is sheer
garbage it is not true it's not true
William bard did not lie anywhere here
what happened is that people here's the
real truth Democrats media they're angry
at Robert Muller they cannot direct
their anger at Robert Muller and so they
have misdirected two million bar okay so
the New York Times is reporting right
now that the special council pushed
Attorney General William bar two times
to release more of his investigative
findings in late March after Bauer
outlined the inquiries main conclusions
in a letter to Congress citing a gap
between bars interpretation and Muller's
report according to that letter that we
are talking about the letter revealed
deep concern about how mr. Barr handled
the
release of the special counsels findings
and we have the text of the letter
so here is what Muller actually wrote
info says dear attorney general bar I
previously sent you a letter dated March
25th 2019 that enclosed the introduction
an executive summary for each volume of
the special counsels report marked with
redactions to remove any information
that potentially could be protected by
Federal Rule of Criminal Procedure 6e
that concern declination decisions
that's the declination to to determine
or related to a charged case we also had
marked an additional two sentences for
review and have now confirmed that these
sentences can be released publicly
accordingly the enclosed documents are
in a form that can be released to the
public
consistent with legal requirements and
department policies I am requesting that
you provide these materials to Congress
and authorize their public release at
this time and then here is the here is
the part that everybody is honing in on
as we stated in our meeting of March 5th
and reiterated to the department early
in the afternoon of March 24th the
introductions and executive summaries of
our two-volume report accurately
summarize this office's work in
conclusions the summary letter the
department sent to Congress and released
to the public late in the afternoon of
March 24th did not fully capture the
context nature and substance of this
office's work and conclusions well it
wasn't up to bars who summarized their
work and conclusions it was just up to
him to summarize the conclusions which
is what he said the entire letter says
this is not a full summary of a 450 page
report it is just saying no collusion no
prosecutable obstruction Muller
continues we communicated that concern
to the department on the morning of
March 25th there is no public confusion
about critical aspects of the results of
our investigation
this threatens to undermine a central
purpose for which the department
appointed the special counsel to assure
the public confidence in the outcome of
the investigations well we understand
that the department is reviewing the
full report to determine what is
appropriate for public release a process
that our office is working with you to
complete that process need not too late
release of the enclosed materials
released at this time would alleviate
the misunderstandings that have arisen
and would answer congressional and
public questions about the nature and
outcome of our investigation
in other words Muller wanted them to
release his summary because his summary
said all the mean stuff about Trump and
Barr said I don't want to release that
summary because that summary is going to
confuse people instead people need the
bottom line
Trump ain't going to jail for this stuff
Trump ain't being prosecuted for this
stuff
and then instead of your
characterization of your own report they
can just read the report itself where is
the cover-up the report is fully
available and this is what Barr
testified to this morning under oath
Barr was asked about all of this and he
said listen Robert Muller told me that
he was not really willing to prosecute
President Trump and that the reason he
wasn't willing to prosecute President
Trump had nothing to do with the Office
of Legal Counsel memo on obstruction of
justice and the presidency he just
didn't feel that he had the necessary
evidence to recommend a prosecution one
way or another he left it up to me
here is Barr explaining that today
special counsel Muller stated three
times to us in that meeting in response
to our questioning that he emphatically
was not saying that but for the OLC
opinion he would have found obstruction
he said that in the future the facts of
a case against a president might be such
that a special counsel would recommend
abandoning the OLC opinion but this is
not such a case we did not understand
exactly why the special counsel was not
reaching the a decision and when we
pressed him on it he said that his team
was still formulating the explanation
okay so in other words Muller was not
willing to prosecute Muller was not
willing to recommend a prosecution
Muller told Barr this three separate
times and then Muller is bitching
publicly about oh well inland leaking to
the public about well you guys you
didn't in that initial letter you didn't
include all of my damaging material
about President Trump here's the bottom
line
Muller didn't have the balls to go
forward with an obstruction of justice
charge against the president that is the
bottom line he could have done it he had
the authority to do it he could have
recommended prosecution he didn't why
didn't he because as much as he dislikes
the President of the United States
Robert Muller on the whole is still an
honest man and that means he knew that
he did not have the substance necessary
to sustain an obstruction of justice
prosecution and that had nothing to do
with the Office of Legal Counsel letter
it had nothing to do with the various
definitions of obstruction of justice
used by William Barr as opposed to
Robert Muller which I discussed at the
time Muller his definition was very
broad bars definition was more specific
but even under Muller's definition he
didn't feel
had the evidence necessary to go forward
the reason that he declined to make a
decision on obstruction he's because he
wanted to humiliate president Trump and
lay out groundwork for impeachment he
can read the report it is obvious from
the report that that's what is going on
and then he sent that report to bar and
bar said okay well all I need to say as
Attorney General is no prosecution on
obstruction and then motors like why
didn't you include all the damaging
material that's the stuff I want out
there and the answer is because that is
not your job the job of the Special
Counsel is not to reveal to the public
damaging information about people who
are not being prosecuted in fact that is
not the job of law enforcement anywhere
it is not the job of law enforcement to
do what James Comey did to Hillary
Clinton where he revealed every detail
of the investigation pointing toward her
prosecution and then said and by the way
we're not prosecuting it was terrible
for Hillary Clinton that he did that and
Hillary's camp had a proper complaint
the counselor complained on the right
was you just explained why she should be
prosecuted why aren't you prosecuting
that I think was a more accurate
complaint but if Comey wasn't gonna
prosecute then spilling his guts in
public about all of his feelings about
Hillary Clinton that is not the job of
law enforcement can you imagine if every
time law enforcement investigated anyone
they just dumped out into the public
all of this damaging material about
people that is not prosecutable these
are not muckraking journalist it's the
job of journalists and congressional
investigators to get to damaging
material it is the job of our criminal
justice system to get to criminal
behavior I remember probably a year back
there was a shooting I believe is in
Dallas it was a bad shooting there was a
police officer an off-duty police
officer who accidentally walked into
somebody else's apartment thought that
the person in the apartment was actually
in her apartment and proceeded to shoot
that person to death the person happen
to be a black person who is in his own
apartment and then the Dallas Police
Department if I'm I think it was Dallas
so I just want to make sure may be wrong
here but I'm fairly certain it was
Dallas the Dallas Police Department then
publicly released the information that
this guy who'd been shot in his own
apartment for doing nothing had pot in
the apartment and a lot of people
correctly pointed out including me why
are you smearing the dead guy he didn't
do anything
what enforcement's job is not to smear
people law enforcement's job is to
enforce the law so why is Muller so
focused on smearing
from you and by smear I don't mean he's
saying stuff that isn't true about Trump
it was true there was pot in this guy's
apartment - I'm saying that it's not the
job of law enforcement and now he's mad
that bar would not participate in this
game where you humiliate the president
but you don't prosecute him and that
somehow bar is fault if Muller had the
courage of his convictions he would have
pushed obstruction and if he knew that
ward there was no obstruction
he has no complaint here in a second I
have a little bit more to say on this
because it really is perverse I mean
what the Democrats are doing now at bar
is perverse get to that in a second
first window treatments it's one of
those solace adulting terms for
something necessary but boring your
blinds you don't even think about them
unless you move or they break but when
they are right everything in your home
looks better when they're wrong
everything in your home looks cheap and
tawdry let's be honest taking the time
to pick out and buy blinds sounds
expensive kind of boring installing them
yourself sounds harder than any
self-respecting adult wants to admit but
blinds.com makes it really easy for you
you're not sure what you want or even
where to start with blinds calm you got
a free online design consultation just
send them pictures of your house they
send back custom recommendations from a
professional from what will work with
your color scheme furniture specific
rooms they will even send you free
samples to make sure everything looks as
good in person as it does online every
order gets free shipping here's the best
part
if you accidentally miss measure or if
you picked the wrong color if you make
the mistake blinds calm remakes your
blinds for free
they made it incredibly easy for you so
you have no more excuses to leave up
those mangled blinds that make your
place look like a sent from the wire for
a limited time get 20% off everything at
blinds comm when you use promo code Ben
that is blinds.com promo code Ben for
20% off everything faux wood blinds
cellular shades roller shades and more
blinds.com promo code Ben rules and
restrictions apply go check it out right
now okay so as I say Democrats are now
pushing forward with the idea that bar
must be impeached based on nothing so
here's representative ted Lieu who's a
joke of a representative out here in
california I mean I know the people in
his district here's a representative Lou
suggesting the bar lied now he can't
name the specific lie that bar told
because bar hasn't lied doesn't matter
somebody must have lied somewhere even
though the report is public guys there's
no lie when the report is public there's
not a cover-up what is he even talking
about here is Lou we know the Attorney
General chooses every single word
carefully do you think he lied to
Congress
I do but let's just take a step back and
see how extraordinary it is what Bill
Barr did not only did he write a
four-page summary than mislead American
people he was then towed by robert
muller that he misled the american
people then he lies in front of congress
and then he does a press conference
misleading american people again it is
incredible the actions he took he
actually needs to go and then he can
apply to be White House press secretary
where he can lie all he wants he didn't
lie there is no lie
name the lie nonetheless you've got
Donna lemon on CNN very objective
journalism in journalism a everywhere
getting the journalism all over the
place here is Don Lemon on CNN
explaining partisan work for the rule of
law to his fellow block of wood chris
cuomo there appears to be collusion
between the President of the United
States and the Attorney General when
you're supposed to be the party of the
rule of law when you have a president
and the Attorney General who are not
fighting for the rule of law but who are
carrying the water for indecent and
inappropriate and possibly even unlawful
behavior what is gonna upset you what
are you gonna take issue it is there
anything what are you even what what are
you talking about
the report is public you idiots the
report is public everyone can read it I
have read it you can read it if you are
capable of reading English it is
possible for you to read it right now
for free on the Justice Department
website the Justice Department headed by
William Barr
wit what Howard's the eye on us to God
have no explanation for how people in
the media and on the left are making the
claim that Barr is working against the
rule of law when he released the full
report and when his original memo
accurately summarizes the findings of
the Moller report according to both your
eyes and also according to robert muller
the guy who's now whining about it
robert muller is only whining because
what he really wanted again for the
thousandth time today what robert muller
really wanted this was obvious from the
report was for the damaging material
about trump to take front and center
stage not the actual finding of the
report but when it comes to criminal
justice the actual finding of the report
is what matters the actual decision
whether to prosecute or not is the thing
that matters in the end and you can't
call it a cover-up if then you release a
four hundred fifty page report replete
the president acting like a jackass how
is that a cover-up you think the report
makes Trump look good the last half of
the report is all about Trump ranting
and raving around the White House and
throwing his wig around and stuff I mean
that's it's crazy that last is a John
Adams reference by the way that that's
totally insane and yet you see the
entire Democratic Party now circulating
if there is no cover-up they have to
manufacture a cover-up and William Barr
is obviously guilty of a cover-up when
in reality there is no cover-up because
you can read it asked about has his
original letter buyer has testified that
his letter was designed to deliver the
verdicts of the investigation and
nothing more which was obvious from the
text of the letter I read you the entire
letter in its entirety I think twice on
the show totally crazy and now you've
got the New York Times saying it seems
pretty important for the goj to release
the earlier Muller letter the one from
March 25th we have to hear about molars
opinions on this stuff okay fine then
subpoena Miller and haven't testified
and then we can have Muller testify
about how he thought Trump was rude and
arrogant and obnoxious and terrible and
then he can also testify as members of
his team have already testified that
there was no obstruction that people
were not prevented from speaking with
people that the White House was
transparent with the Muller
investigation except for specific
instances named in the Muller report and
that put report we know about because
it's public just insanity Maxine Waters
the dumbest person this side of a potato
says William Barr should resign or be
impeached I'm always excited to hear
Maxine Waters one of the most corrupt
members of Congress of last half-century
talked about when people ought to be
impeached
after she used her perch at the House
Financial Services Committee to
allegedly funnel money to a bank in
which her husband was an investor here
is Maxine Waters explaining from her
high moral perch atop which she has
suggested that the LA riots which ended
in some dead and and probably billions
of dollars in property damage that was
an uprising according to Maxine Waters
she's the light but I want to hear her
opinions about the rule of law I think
the bar should resign and if he does not
resign he should be facing impeachment
proceedings also he is abdicated on his
responsibility he has lied he has used
the very words coming
right out of the president's mouth no
collusion no collusion no collusion and
made a decision that despite what the
Special Counsel put into that report
about obstruction of justice he said he
made the decision that he had not
obstructed justice it is outrageous and
he needs to go okay everything that you
just said is an accurate summation and
nothing about it is wrong
there was no collusion Muller didn't
even object to that part of the of the
summary letter and as far as Barr saying
that he was not prosecuting and it was
his decision it is his decision he's the
Attorney General and robert muller
didn't make a recommendation again if
Robert Muller wanted to prosecute he had
the capacity to recommend a prosecution
he declined to do so which means it was
now up to William Bar and when William
bar said I don't have the evidence to do
that and then Miller says well you know
I kind of agree with that but there's
all this stuff over here I wish he had
mentioned about her Trump's a big Meany
and Barr was like well good news in four
weeks we're gonna release the whole
thing where is the controversy here this
is all manufactured Anderson Cooper he
to journalism in all over the place all
over the CNN set Anderson Cooper he says
bars letter looks like a love letter a
sweet sweet lovemaking letter to
President Trump I think there's an
argument in defense a bar that says he
was doing what he was supposed to do and
yes you can argue with how he
characterized it publicly and coming up
he did characterize her into your point
in literally repeating the words of the
president it seemed as much of a love
letter to the President as possible from
an attorney Jack yeah but he included
the key line which was that he couldn't
you know establish stadium structure
does nor exonerate him I mean if you
were doing the sound bite you'd lift
that line and write yes
okay well that final that final
representation that is not being made
thereby by Anderson Cooper well what's
the name of this this person I can't I
can't remember the name of this
particular reporter but in any case the
reporter who's speaking at the last year
is being accurate its Anderson Cooper
who's being inaccurate it's a love
letter it's a love letter it's not a
love letter it was a summary of
conclusions alone this is such a
manufactured nonsensical controversy but
you know go for it guys go for it it's
just it's amazing it's amazing okay
meanwhile controversy chaos continues to
break out in Venezuela will
bring you the latest on that controversy
that is breaking out with regard to
Venezuela momentarily but first let's
talk about the fact that you need to
make your business better you do okay
the fact is that your business you
require better employees the best way to
do that is zip recruiter zip recruiter
sends your job to over 100 the web's
leading job boards they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiters against thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and then invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zipper courier analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you're
never gonna miss a great match zip
recruiter is so effective that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day and right now my listeners can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire that is zip recruiter comm
slash daily wired Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter comm slash of daily wire zip
recur is indeed the smartest way to hire
and there's no reason for you to use any
dumber way to hire when zip recruiter
makes it so incredibly easy for you all
you have to do is go check them out for
free right now at zip recruit comm slash
daily wire there's a reason that when we
are looking for employees then we
ourselves here at daily wear use zip
recruiter you can to zip recruiters comm
slash daily wear go check them out right
now okay we're gonna bring you the
updates on Venezuela momentarily first
you're gonna have to go subscribe over
at daily wire comm $9.99 a month gets
you subscriptions to this show which is
the best show come on guys it's awesome
also you get two additional hours of the
show every single afternoon where we
have fantastic guests in the last couple
of days we've had the rabbi who is shot
at Chabad of Poway on the show we have
had senators we have had governors we
have had the vice president's of the
United States on the show we have lots
of great guests on the show all the time
plus my incisive and brilliant
commentary for two additional hours a
day and because our show is basically
split because we do a morning show and
an afternoon show it's basically like
having me in your ear 24 hours a day
which is my wife's worst nightmare but
your dream so go check it out right now
and for $99 a year you also get this the
greatest sin all beverage vessels the
leftist cheers hot or cold tumbler cast
your eyes upon it and see the joy that
can flow through you if only you had
this in your hand for $99 a year you can
have that in here hey you can have this
leftist here's how to call tumblr right
there on your desk right now also you
got access to our Sunday specials a day
early I can't reveal
to who our new Sunday special guests are
going to be that we are filming this
week I can just say they are
awesomesauce so go check that out right
now also as I have mentioned before we
are the second largest podcast in
America period okay and you can make us
the first largest podcast if you tell
all of your friends to watch us over at
YouTube or download us at SoundCloud or
iTunes go check us out leave us review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in America
you
all righty so quick correction the note
the the reporter who is speaking on that
Anderson Cooper clip is a David Gregory
okay so on to Venezuela because I'm sick
of talking about a non traversée which
is this bar thing let's talk about an
actual serious situation in Venezuela so
the latest in Venezuela is new protests
have broken out apparently there are
reports that Nicolas Maduro is basically
on the ropes at this point that Maduro
is effectively waiting to be sent out of
the country and back to Cuba and that he
would have that would have happened
yesterday except that Russia talked him
out of it
it's amazing to watch Americans who
supposedly hate Russian collusion now
collude with Russia in their interest in
Venezuela bunch of folks huh I haven't
heard a word from Bernie Sanders about
Venezuela as this is happening not one
for Millhone Omar not one from ALC
nothing nada zip zilch
nothing okay that's pretty weird since
people are getting run over by socialist
Humvees over in Venezuela right now it
seems like a good time to talk about how
maybe a popular left uprising okay Quan
fido is not on the right in Venezuela
how that might be a good thing to
mention but the Russians who basically
maintained the Maduro should stay in
power according to Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo on CNN yesterday Nicolas
Maduro the socialist evil dictator of
Venezuela who has overrun all democratic
boundaries he was ready to leave he was
on the tarmac yesterday and then Russia
talked him out of it throughout the day
it's been a long time since anyone has
seen Maduro he had an airplane on the
tarmac he was ready to leave this
morning as we understand it and the
Russians indicated he should stay we
think the situation remains incredibly
fluid we know that there were senior
leaders inside the Maduro government
that were prepared to leave they told us
as much over the past few weeks and
we're convinced that the Venezuelan
people are going to get their democracy
back the American Left which is still
harkening back to its glory days
stumping for the Soviet Union during the
Cold War they're still arguing that
America has no role whatsoever in public
pressure on Venezuela a lot of people
isolationist right and on the on the
Left suggesting that it's American
involvement in Venezuela that's the
problem
okay Russia is active there Russia is
making sure that Maduro who's an evil
dictator stays in power with troops
capable of shooting on the population
okay and in in opposition
to millions of people who have been
reduced to eating dogs in one of the
most oil-rich countries on planet earth
and that Cuba is active there so here's
the choice yeah this is the truth about
so much of American foreign policy when
America does not play a role that is not
left as a vacuum when America does not
play a role there are other powers in
the world who do not have such qualms
about quote-unquote imperialism and they
get involved immediately it is much more
imperialistic for Russia to be propping
up a socialist dictator who is who is
basically centralized military command
so we can shoot dissenters there's a
difference between that and the United
States saying hey look a popular
opposition maybe we should lend them
diplomatic support is it and yet you see
the left running headlong away from this
the latest from Venezuela is that
thousands of pro phyto demonstrators are
gathering in Caracas again according to
CNN which by the way has been turned off
in Venezuela Venezuela the government
has prevented CNN from broadcasting so
don't worry the true threat the real
threat as we all know to the press is
right here in America I mean Jim Acosta
was saying as much yesterday Jim Acosta
actually tweeted out a picture of
himself reading his new audio book
here's what he tweeted putting my vocal
cords to the test this week recording
the audio version of my book out in June
the enemy of the people a dangerous time
to tell the truth in America the studio
placed me in the u2 sweet love that
because it is a dangerous time to tell
the truth in America when you can be in
an air-conditioned sweet audio reading
your book from the u2 sweet actually as
your own network is being shut down in
Venezuela obviously the true threat to
press freedom as president from saying
mean things to Jim Acosta because I mean
Jim Acosta that too loves him some Jim
Acosta in any case CNN is reporting that
in Venezuela these crowds are gathering
in the heart of the Opposition in in
Venezuela as capital they're not showing
signs of moving anywhere just yet quite
Oh tweeted today that he would see
people in the streets he said to our
workers we recognize the value of
dignified work which affords you
well-being in progress today we know
there is no salary which reaches that
and that your rights and achievements
are ignored May first we accompany you
and your demands see you in the street
john bolton has said that Maduro is now
surrounded by scorpions in a bottle
he said Maduro spent the day not in the
company of Venezuelan forces but
surrounded by Cubans because he doubted
the loyalty of zone Venezuelan Armed
Forces
so the military it seems may be turning
on on Maduro which is a very good thing
john bolton had said yesterday that all
options are on the table that if that if
for example Maduro were to start
launching missiles at his own people the
united states might get involved now
let's make clear the united states is
not getting involved in venezuela trump
does not want to be involved the
administration does not want to be
involved I know virtually everyone in
the administration this is not something
they are seeking but Barack Obama
everyone every president always says all
options on the table because guess what
when you're the United States all
options are always on the table just
somewhere off to the side of the table
you know we don't want it we don't want
to break that glass and hit the button
if we have to we will but that's not
something we want here's John Bolton
explaining all the options are on the
table let me say two things to be very
clear number one we want as our
principal objective the peaceful
transfer of power but I will say again
as the president has said from the
outset and that Nicolas Maduro and those
supporting him particularly those who
are not Venezuelan should know is all
options are on the table okay so that
you know obviously it's not something
that he wants in a second I'm gonna get
to the left opposition to this and it's
really amazing so the left is happy to
defend the worst people in the world in
Venezuela namely Nicolas Maduro and his
allies in Cuba and Russia it's pretty
incredible okay now who's a congress
person from out in California he
suggested that America is responsible
for maduras Humvees driving over
civilian protesters yesterday it's
America's fault always according to the
radical left everything is America's
fault it's never to America's credit
when good things happen it's always
America's fault when bad things happen
the Vice President shouldn't be
interfering and inciting violence with
wydo
what we should be doing is deferring to
the Pope to have a negotiated settlement
or Uruguay or Mexico and it looks like
the United States is getting inching
into yet another bloody conflict and
this is not going to be easy then as
will is one of the most armed nations in
the world 1.6 million militias the
military appears divided between Guido
and Madero and the question is is this
really the United States role to get
involved in yet another
war overseas okay so this is the new
claim the claim is that America's
getting involved in a war overseas we
should leave it to the Russians and
Maduro that's how you should do now
America's not getting involved in a war
over there we're not getting involved
militarily that's not something number
one we need to do the fact is that
Venezuela is surrounded by states that
do not like Nicolas Maduro because
Nicolas Maduro is a threat to the region
as well as to his own country I'm sort
of amazed though by there are some
people on the right who have been making
the same sort of claim why do we care
about what happens in Venezuela so
Tucker Carlson a guy who I really like
where I'm friends with Tucker but Tucker
is is an isolationist on foreign policy
or at least largely isolationist on
foreign policy and Tucker last night he
he started asking so why are we even
meddling in Venezuela what's the purpose
I'll explain why in just a second when
was the last time we successfully
meddled in the political life of another
country has it ever worked
how are those democracies we set up in
Iraq in Libya and Syria and Afghanistan
tonight how would Venezuela be different
please explain and take your time so
what's the point of doing that so our
lawmakers can feel like good people and
if they are indeed good people why do
they seem to care more about Venezuela
than they care about this country the
one that they run they're happy to send
our military to South America at the
first sign of chaos but US troops to our
own border to stem the tide of a hundred
thousand uninvited arrivals a month
nowhere they tell us that's crazy talk
okay well no okay so a couple of things
one
nobody cares about Venezuela more than
they care about the United States nobody
is even talking about deploying military
force in any serious way in Venezuela
but why should we care well one of the
things that Tucker cares about
presumably is illegal immigration he's
very strong on illegal immigration the
number of Venezuelan immigrants in the
United States rose from two hundred
sixteen thousand in 2014 it's a three
hundred fifty one thousand in 2017 a
growth of sixty one thousand in one year
alone
according to migration policy org and
that is I believe just legal immigrants
to the United States that does not
include illegal immigration to the
United States one of the reasons we've
seen heavy illegal immigration to the
United States in recent years is
specifically because of the enormous
amount of chaos in South and Central
America as far as what is the last time
that the United States successfully
imposed democracy well let's see after
World War two we did it in Germany we
also did it in Japan we were successful
in staving off a communist takeover of
Italy in the aftermath of world war two
South Korea is a democracy
because we were involved in the Korean
or Vietnam today would be a democracy if
we had not precipitously pulled out of
Vietnam as far as Iraq Iraq was a
functioning democracy until we decided
to precipitously pull out and hand it
over to Iran and Isis so actually the
United States has a pretty solid record
in a lot of these areas and as far as
how Venezuela is different from Iraq how
Venezuela is different from Syria I mean
there are not a lot of similarities
Venezuela had a functioning democracy
before ago Chavez took that democracy
and turned it into a socialist
dictatorship and in fact the opposition
in Venezuela is being put up by the
National Assembly which they
democratically elected body so these are
not similar anyway Syria has no history
of democracy Syria has been a tribal
dictatorship for decades at this point
without any history of functioning
democracy the same is not true in
Venezuela so to simply equate these
countries is not accurate and as far as
American involvement again if we are not
getting heavily involved I failed to see
why why are you like what's the
objection is are we better off with
Maduro in power in Venezuela having an
entrenched anti-american socialist who
threatens his neighbors and serves as a
launching platform for America's enemies
is that better than having a functioning
democracy with somebody who is
relatively Pro America there I don't see
why what really yeah you know Tucker I
think is is by nature somebody who
doesn't want to get involved overseas
which is fine I'm yeah I don't think
anybody really wants again nobody I'm
not interested in getting involved
militarily in Venezuela but to pretend
that American rhetoric can retreat from
the world and that our enemies will not
just take over territories I mean this
is basic Monroe Doctrine type stuff I
mean it has been true since the early
19th century that America suggested that
we shouldn't have foreign powers
encroaching in our hemisphere because it
was a threat to America's national
security that remains true today and I
wonder if Tucker would have felt the
same way during the Cuban Missile Crisis
when Russia was invading what was in was
using the Cuban Revolution as an excuse
to place missiles 90 miles from
America's heartland
90 miles from Cuba and 90 miles from
Florida rather what do you say why are
we getting involved in Cuba what does
this have to do with us well has
something to do with us since they're
right there if Venezuela has something
to do with us and as the world grows
smaller America is involved in foreign
policies that do affect us here at home
both economically and in terms of
terrorism and immigration there are a
lot of complex issues that are there are
a lot more complicated than simply why
do we care about Venezuela and caring
about Venezuela more than we do I just
don't I don't buy any of that I just
don't think that that is correct in any
case the most the funniest point about
Venezuela yesterday was actually made by
an MSNBC reporter so an MSNBC reporter
unwittingly makes the strong case for
the second amendment yesterday pretty
hilarious he appears to still control
the military you have to understand in
Venezuela gun ownership is not something
that is open to everybody so if the
military have the guns they have the
power and as long as Nicolas Maduro
controls the military he controls the
country okay so that that is hilarious
that is hilarious only in that that is
exactly the case that's Kerry Sanders of
MSNBC making the case for why Americans
should not give up their guns because it
turns out that when you give up all your
guns to a centralized government that
government then controls all aspects of
your life
so MSNBC welcome to the Second Amendment
camp I really appreciate you joining
welcome to the party gang alrighty time
for some things that I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today there is a great video that
is out from Jonathan Sacks Jonathan
Sacks was the chief rabbi of the United
Kingdom there's a great video that is
put out it's a scribing video so it's
kind of a drone video really neat to
watch you should go check it out about
the connection between Judaism in Israel
what we've watched over the last several
years really over the last 15 to 20
years is the left try and suggest that
you can be in favor of the extermination
of the State of Israel but that's not
anti-semitic so simply getting rid of
the single largest repository of Jews on
planet earth not anti-semitic
disestablishing Israel as a Jewish state
not anti-semitic rabbi sacks blows up
that notion in in this five minute video
we'll play a little clip of it and you
should go check it out yourself
how can anti-zionism either new
anti-semitism surely there's no
connection between them anti-semitism is
hatred of Jews as a people a race an
ethnic group anti-zionism is an
objection to a country a nation a state
what is the connection between them
okay and then he goes on and explains
what the connection is between them
watch the video it's a great six minute
explanation that is purely intuitive and
understandable and common-sense about
why it is that hatred of Jews has now
morphed into hatred of Israel bottom
line is that over history Jews have been
corporately attacked whether as a
religion or as a culture or as a race
and now as a state that's what's
happening with regard to the State of
Israel right now okay time for some
quick things and what we actually one
more one more quick thing that I like so
I do have to note here Stacey Abrams who
has made a big fuss about how she's the
actual governor of Georgia she has not
in fact the governor of Georgia
she continues to maintain that she is
but she doesn't have the the intestinal
fortitude to run for Senate so she says
that she is not going to run for Senate
in Georgia why because she understands
that last time around was kind of an
aberration and she'll get skunked here
if she is explaining that she will not
be a senator from Georgia I am
announcing today that I will not be a
candidate for the United States Senate I
am so grateful for all of the support
and encouragement I've received from
fellow Georgians to leaders of Congress
and beyond
however the fights to be waged require a
deep commitment to the job and I do not
see the US Senate as the best role for
me in this battle for our nation's
future but let's be clear I will do
everything in my power to ensure Georgia
Alexa Democrat to the United States
Senate in 2020 except for running so
that's not happening so the Democrats
have have lost out on a bunch of
candidates who are supposedly strong
candidates for Senate come 2020 which
suggests they may not be as strong going
into 2020 as they purport to be okay
time for some things that I hate
okay so Angela Davis is a is a former
terrorist and an anti-semite
she's also hailed around the left as
some sort of heroine she was almost
certainly involved in the shooting of a
federal judge for which she was labeled
to terrorists and put on the FBI's top
ten most wanted list now she wanders
around campuses and is treated as some
sort of decent human being here she was
yesterday speaking out in favor of Ilhan
Omar on Democracy Now a repository of
leftist stupidity it's not a shock that
Angela Davis who is not a fan of Jews is
also a fan of Ilhan Omar who is not a
fan of the Jews here is Angela Davis
explaining I am extremely proud that
finally we've elected someone to
Congress who speaks out in such a
powerful way on behalf of black women on
behalf of Palestinians on behalf of all
people who are oppressed the Angela
Davis is a joke the fact that she is
still seen as someone worthy of
emulation on the left demonstrates the
moral bankruptcy of the left she called
herself a political prisoner even though
she was involved in an act of terrorism
okay she because she was involved in
that act of terrorism with regard to a
federal judge she was quoted as saying
of Czech dissidents quote they of the
Soviets use of Stalinist Angela Davis
and now she has a an intellectual so she
was quoted as saying of Czech dissidents
according to mosaic they deserve what
they get let them remain in prison
according to Alan Dershowitz he asked
for her help for Jewish refuseniks and
other prisoners of conscience in the
Soviet Union
she told him quote they're all Zionist
fascists and opponents of socialism
she's a joy I'm so glad that Democrats
continue to maintain that Angela Davis
is a person worthy of our respect okay
other things that I hate today so the
Editorial Board of the New York Times
has now run an editorial about how
terrible they were for running this
horribly anti-semitic cartoon and their
editorial is actually quite good at the
editorial acknowledges that anti-semitic
imagery is particularly dangerous now
they talk about the rise in
anti-semitism they say this is also a
period of rising criticism of Israel
much of it directed at the rightward
drift of its own government some of it
even questioning Israel's very
foundation as a Jewish state we have
been and remain stalwart supporters of
Israel this is the New York Times
editorial board No
no you have not an entire article in
National Review today about how you have
a long history of hating the State of
Israel and seeking to ally with those
who would destroy it the New York Times
says we believe that good faith
criticism should work to strengthen
Israel over the long term by helping it
stay true to its democratic values which
is the way of saying we have always
hoped to undermine the State of Israel
by appealing to generalized democratic
principles that don't actually apply in
the way we say they apply anti-zionism
says the times can clearly serve as a
cover for anti-semitism now look at even
the language there so New York Times is
being hailed as as look how honest they
were they're coming forward well first
of all there I haven't seen them change
their editorial coverage of Israel I'm
looking forward to the next 20
editorials about how Benjamin Netanyahu
is the true obstacle to peace in the
Middle East an alchemist is really the
voice of an oppressed people but look at
the language there anti-zionism can
clearly serve as a cover for
anti-semitism and some criticism of
Israel as the cartoon demonstrated is
couched openly in anti-semitic terms
that phrase anti-zionism can clearly
serve as a cover for anti-semitism no
anti-zionism is anti-semitism if you say
that the Jews can't have a state as
opposed to Christians having many states
and constituting a majority in a wide
bevy of states and that Muslims have 50
odd states but the Jews can't have a
state the Jews cannot exist as a
corporate body as a religious body they
can't exist but that's that's just cover
for anti-semitism you don't get the
problem at New York Times of course they
don't because they are an anti Zionist
Organization so you know here's my
feeling yeah they're earning all sorts
of praise particularly from their own
employees today I'm saying columnist at
the New York Times shockingly coming out
in defense of the New York Times look at
our beautiful editorial how about this
change your coverage and then we'll talk
about whether you have figured out your
anti-semitism problem okay so we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours there's a lot I wanted
to get to on today's show that I
couldn't which is why you should
subscribe because then you can see all
of it later two additional hours later
today so we'll see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam SIA
Vettes audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant NIC Sheehan the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today well
they've got Trump this time they've
they've really got him this time they
the left now claims that a Washington
Post report confirms that the Attorney
General obstructed justice for Trump
except the only problem of course is
that the Washington Post report confirms
exactly the opposite of that we'll talk
about it also does the president's love
for tweeting help or hurt his reelection
chances we'll try to figure that out and
schools in Virginia claim that there are
thousands of transgender students
enrolled in their schools if that's true
what does it actually tell us we'll
discuss all that today over on the Matt
Walsh show